[Musique]
j'utilise seulement plusieurs aromates
mais le but c'est vraiment d'intégrer la
forêt puis tout non résolues en fait
sont comestibles ou québec on est venu
chercher aujourd'hui les poses de sapins
c'est ce que sont peu salon bhr
contentement qui sont encore enroulés on
voit le qui sont fermée sur elle-même
cela commence à se déployer jeu sans le
sou ariane l'or est fasciné par le
terroir depuis que sa mère lui a fait
goûter et biscuits ou cèdre elle veut
faire découvrir à son tour les saveurs
d'ici on voit vraiment la peau ce qui
est verte et plus parle plus vraiment pu
tendre qu'elle reste la branche donc
alain moussy d'horreur et plus sucré un
peu et - résineuses quelque chose moi
que j'aime particulièrement dans le
sapin ou quelque chose de réconfortant
veux pas ça nous rappelle un peu haut
sur l'arbre de noël tu penses vraiment
un arbre qu'on a à s'approprier qui est
tellement autour de lui installé à la
pocatière à rien a fait des études en
cueillette et transformation des
champignons forestiers
son armoire à épices est ici dans la
région du bas-saint-laurent au
kamouraska là où la végétation est
adapté un climat plus froid climat
boréale souvent on pense que c'est très
fort le sapin mais la peau c'est quand
même assez douces l'ayant même qui vont
donc une petite note de barbe à papa
août c'est quelque chose d'assez secret
moi je les utilise vraiment en épices
donc des fois et fusils mais surtout
même en épices broyer sécher et broyés
puis j'assaisonne meeples donc surtout
les desserts je suis très tard je vends
mes plats en ligne sont surtout des
desserts collation des éléments déjà mis
les gourmandises mais à savoir mourir
donc j'utilise plusieurs épices ou du
petit fruit dans mes confection donc
c'est vraiment le but de mettre en
valeur lorsqu'on autour de nous kébé
aujourd'hui on va utiliser les poses de
sapins pour faire des guimauves est ce
qu'on va faire c'est que on va ajouter
de l'eau ou tout simplement avec la
gélatine pour la faire gonfler et nous
pousse de sapins sont broyés
par la suite quand ça va être gonflé on
va rajouter 10 où on va chauffer un peu
la préparation on la laisse tempéré pour
ajouter le mélange qu'un fusil de
certains pour lui du monde on l'a mais
après dans le bas des ressources eau ou
à la mixette ça peut se faire rare la
maison à la mixette l'heure l'important
c'est qu'il faut battre assez longtemps
donc environ une dizaine de minutes le
talent qui en fait la préparation
prennent du volume
[Musique]
moscou
on
a c'est léger aérien sa goudou mets
sucrés sur preneur ailleurs m quand
est-ce que je pars au campo
moche une seconde pâtisserie et granola
autant de gâteries revisité avec une
touche boréale sa dernière création la
crème brûlée ou champignons si on
cuisine des légumes depuis longtemps
dans les desserts en fait grades aux
carottes ont fait donc pourquoi pas avec
les champignons qui est des belles
propriétés qui permet d'aller chercher
aussi beaucoup de l'huma me donc le
cinquième ou qu'on dit on pourrait
utiliser plusieurs champignons là dedans
il y en a quand même eu plusieurs qui se
prête bien aux dessins mais inquiétant
car bien sûr c'est le lactaire odeurs
des rames c'est un champignon vraiment
particulier par son parfum qui par son
moteur on va pas c'est que ça sent les
rendent c'est vrai mais c'est surtout le
biscuit l érable qui dégage comme odeurs
on va prendre en fait les champignons
qui ont été des ide rhatigan sont
déshydratés on peut se les procurer à
l'année nous ce qu'on va utiliser ses
moulu pour les besoins de la recette
aujourd'hui donc on va intégrer en fait
ces champignons là qui ont été tranchées
déshydraté dans une crème qualité
chauffer un petit peu donc là ça va
permettre de tout libérer des parfums je
pense que toutes les plantes peuvent
être utilisés d'inscrits ainsi vraiment
notre imagination qui nous limite
dans son jardin ariane fait pousser
quelques plantes mais comptent surtout
sur des petits producteurs locaux comme
charles antoine franc de lyon qui
cultive la monarde doit être j'ai aussi
une planche de mode à stylo
moi je trouve que la dîme ans donc celle
que la fleur rouge de la goutte un petit
peu plus le ton qui la fistule est plus
proche de leur gagne plus petits comme
je trouve la monarde lorsqu'elle arrive
le lycées schisme au moins je laisse ça
à la maison lorsque je l'accueille dans
le jardin puis par la suite et les
moulures moi je les utilise beaucoup un
assemblage avec d'autres épices donc
souvent je mélange de cette épice bien
sûr boréale dont la monarde qui permet
d'agrémenter mais plus que je mets
vraiment dans différentes choses que je
peux le comparer à un chien ou un
mélange montréal qu'on peut utiliser la
différence afrique par exemple je fais
des caramels avec ses épices là qui
rappelle un peu même le paye des peas ou
quatre épices à la limite qui connaît le
clou de girofle
des pistes pour la monarde intégré à son
mélange de cette épice est utilisé dans
plusieurs de ses produits gourmands dont
les compets
c'est vraiment simple puis c'est en
train paniqués qui est un mot revenant à
glee je dirais mais ça vient de
l'angleterre un bon petit déjeuner nous
a sauvés
proposer des gourmandises original
ancrés dans leur territoire demande de
la recherche du travail un projet qu
ariane tient à bout de bras de la
préparation de ses créations à la mise
en marché
sur les hauteurs du kamouraska ariane
leur nourrisson rêve de faire connaître
les richesses de notre terroir son
entreprise a récemment reçu une bourse
pour l'inde et dans la poursuite de ces
recherches je pense en train de se passe
au québec que les gens ont le goût de
découvrir leurs arguments et de les
transformer mais souvent c'est plus
tentants lorsque ont cédé juste que ça
goûte foncé abbaoui moi si je capable
j'écoute mars à la maison
[Musique]